It's been a busy couple of days for the space flight community.
NASA's New Horizons spacecraft made its closest approach to the dwarf planet Pluto...
...on Tuesday at 7:50 AM Eastern.
New Horizons has already sent back a ton of interesting images and data.
The spacecraft recently solved a long-standing debate within the scientific community.
How big is Pluto really?
Turns out it's around 1,473 miles in diameter.
That makes Pluto the largest object that we know of in the Kuiper Belt,...
...the big region of icy bodies at the edge of our solar system.
There's also a lot of excitement surrounding Pluto's surface features.
On one side, Pluto has what it looks like a large white heart.
On either side of the heart are two big dark splotches,...
...recently given the terrifying names Cthulhu and Balrog.
But scientists still aren't sure what kind of formations they are.
High-resolution imaging of Pluto's surface revealed icy mountains over 11,000 feet high,...
...that's six times One World Trade.
Right now, New Horizons is moving even farther away from Pluto,...
...but it's still studying the tiny world.
After that, New Horizons is faded with wandering the cosmos forever.
Well, until it breaks down.